talk is going to be by Evan Sadler
Evan would you like to share your screen
and unmute yourself so you can we can
all hear you
yes thank you meeting is good okay I
wanted to put it into a full screen mode
yeah yep
there we go
uh we're all set for the recording
yeah okay great so I'm very happy to uh
introduce the second Talk of the fully
virtual session and and also delighted
to see the amazing attendance we have
online
um the second talk is games on
endogenous networks by Evan Sadler which
is joint work with Ben golub as Ben just
wrote in the chat he's online and can if
you have any questions during the talk
please just type them into the chat Ben
can can answer and then afterwards we'll
have some live q a so uh take it away
Evan all right wonderful thank you so
much uh I'm really happy to be here uh
this is not my first time uh using
gather but uh it seems to be working as
a as well as ever it's kind of a fun
format uh so so this
um so so with this project we're really
trying to think about the interaction
between uh social connections and and
behavior so thinking not just about uh
how how people's network connections
um influences their behavior but then
also in turn how Behavior influenced the
connect the connections that form and
just to kind of illustrate the point
that um it really is important to think
about these these two directions of
causality together uh I wanna just um
briefly you know mentioned this I think
now quite famous study of pure effects
at the U.S Air Force Academy where uh
just to you know give a a quick uh recap
of what the researchers did and and
found in in the study so they sort of
looked at um first year Air Force Cadets
in sort of two successive waves uh first
year basically random assignment to
squadrons So within a squadron you're
sort of you know attending all of your
classes together uh so it's sort of a
very tight-knit
um but you know administratively created
group and it seemed like uh you know
because that's who uh came in with uh
sort of you know low test scores weren't
expected to do well academic
academically it seemed like they did
better if they were in a squadron with
more
um peers who had high uh sat verbal
scores
and I also in the um you know second
wave of the study uh after estimating
these beer effects in the in the first
wave they wanted to do some social
engineering trying to help out the
students sort of at the you know left
tail of the distribution
and so they constructed some squadrons
in which they had sort of a relatively
higher fraction of these uh lower
performing students in a relatively High
fraction of students with high test
scores and you know they expected there
to be you know a positive effect of of X
on the performance of the you know left
tail uh but actually it turned out that
they had a negative effect that was
comparably sized so this sort of
attempted social engineering uh really
backfired and you know part of the
postmortem analysis is really the you
know what what went wrong uh is that you
know peer groups are are very much
endogenous even within the
administratively assigned groups
um the the friendships that generated
positive care effects uh under random
assignment didn't seem to form as much
in the um in the engineered group so
this is just to say that we really do
need a frame work to think about
you know how how sort of both directions
of causality are going to mutually
influence one another so you know we're
interested in how how this
interdependence shapes outcomes when
um when uh linking requires Mutual
consent so
uh so it's a broad overview we're gonna
introduce a very you know abstract
General framework to think about uh
games in which uh players are going to
form links and uh but also engage in
some sort of strategic interaction in
the network that forms
okay so this is we're going to do this
in a way to Nest
um sort of standard models of each kind
of a direction on its own so it'll Nest
standard models of Network games it'll
Nest
um some standard Network formation
models
and our our notion of a stable outcome
is going to exactly correspond to you
know National equilibrium in the network
game pairwise stability in uh in in the
network formation aspect of it
okay so beyond you know just introducing
these definitions we're going to
identify some order conditions on
payoffs that are going to lead to simple
Network structures uh in stable outcomes
and now our our results go you know
quite a quite a bit beyond this but I'm
gonna uh spend most of my time talking
about a special class of um uh separable
games because here the order conditions
have a I think of particularly natural
interpretation so we can think of one
um one dimension being whether
spillovers are positive or negative so
you'd think that there's an order ring
on the on the actions that players are
taking and spillovers are positive if
taking a higher action makes me a more
attractive neighbor so I think like if
uh we're in a pure effects example if on
a you know hard-working student I I
study very hard well maybe uh you're
more you would be more inclined to form
a link with me because you expect uh
that I'll be more helpful in you know
raising your own grades
um negative spillovers would be the
reverse taking a higher action would uh
would make me a less attractive neighbor
in that case the other dimension
um that that is important for our
results is whether actions and links are
compliments or substitutes so you say
actions and links are are compliments so
this um if um whenever I take a higher
action that also makes me want to form
more lengths and the actions and links
are substitutes if uh alternatively if I
take a higher action that makes me say
less inclined to form links so
you know if you think about this being
really within within a single player
it's kind of like allocating effort to
sort of linking versus whatever the
Strategic action is so if I'm in the uh
the purefx example again I might I might
think of this as a case of Action Link
substitutes because well if I'm you know
spending all of my time uh sitting in
front of a book uh studying maybe it's a
little bit more difficult to
um to maintain relationships
okay so the the main result then can can
no I can I can preview as just a simple
two by two table right so give me any
combination of uh spillovers condition
and then Action Link being either a
complements or substitutes and I can
tell you uh in in Broad terms what uh
the graph has to look like in a stable
outcome and uh how actions have to
correspond to uh player's position in
the network
so for instance if we're in the positive
spillovers and complements Corner uh
stable graphs are always nested split
graphs so this is a very strong like
hierarchical structure where
neighborhoods are ordered by set
inclusion and the players with sort of
more friends are going to be taking
higher actions we sort of flip that on
its head if we're in the negative
spillovers in substitutes case uh with
um you know those more friends taking
lower actions in in the other two
corners
um
I get a a different structure that I'll
say more about later because ordered
overlapping cliques but basically you
should think of players being sort of
clustered in groups with their neighbors
taking similar actions
yeah
so
um again kind of uh at a high level we
we think of um sort of
main contribution coming from from a few
different places so uh you know first
giving a a unified treatment of Network
games in strategically formed Networks
um we I I think I think it's
um nice to have uh some some simple and
interpretable conditions that that are
going to give uh quite sharp predictions
about about stable outcomes
um but I think perhaps most excitingly
to me is that you know there's um you
know a lot of very natural applications
and so we um uh are going to spend I'll
spend most of my time on the talk
um talking about sort of a toy model
intended to capture the um the purefx
example uh in the paper we also talk uh
in in at some length about a model of uh
status games and uh
uh some foundations for group matching
models
um
so of course there's you know quite a
large literature uh looking at sort of
both of these
um sort of types of interactions on
their own both sort of Network games and
strategic Network formation
um recently there has been I think I
think quite a bit of interest in uh
understanding more about the
interdependence of links and links and
actions so um most of this work uh so
the paper cited in in the middle are
really looking at um you know unilateral
link formations so players being able to
just decide I want to form a link with
this with this person uh not requiring
Mutual consent so things get a little
bit more uh tricky
um with mutual consent because you have
to consider a sort of coalitional
deviations but there is
um some sort of some some work doing
this not uh not a lot that we're uh
aware of
um I guess relative to the existing work
what we're going to be uh talking about
today
um so it makes far fewer uh you know
parametric assumptions on on the payoff
structure and sort of you know the the
existing work but I'm aware of really
sort of strongly falls into the you know
one particular quadrant of our of our
characterization so we're going to sort
of have a more complete mapping of uh uh
sort of what the what the landscape
looks like
okay
um
let me just ever so briefly pause in
case there's any questions on the
introduction and uh if there aren't I
can just launch right into the framework
Okay so
so networking with network formation is
going to consist of uh you know three
ingredients so it looks a lot like a
normal form game we have players we have
actions and we have payoffs uh the only
thing that's a little bit funny here is
that the
um payoff takes this input not just a
profile of actions but it also takes as
input a graph that forms with the with
the players as the vertices
okay so an outcome
is going to be a pair we need a a graph
G and we need a profile of actions s
okay
uh just to introduce just a little bit
of notation that I'm going to need so
I'm going to write you know given a
particular graph G I'm going to write G
sub I for the the neighborhood of player
I so the set of neighbors
um d sub I is the degree of player I and
I'll write a graph you know G plus or
minus some set of edges e to indicate
that we're thinking about the graph with
that set of edges added or uh or removed
okay
so what um
what is our solution concept so it's
it's you know a stability concept so
we're going to be thinking about
outcomes that are sort of robust to a
particular set of deviations that
players might be able to implement
um so roughly we're thinking Nash
equilibrium in actions and pairwise
stability in links so the and the latter
indicating that you know linking is
going to be by Mutual consent so so
here's the definition
we're going to say that an outcome so
remember this pair of a graph and a
profile of actions uh we'll say that
it's strictly pairwise stable if
if the profile of actions is the Nash
equilibrium of the game holding the
graph fixed
and then also if um holding the actions
fixed there's no link in the graph uh
such that one of the two players wants
to unilaterally remove it
um there's no link missing from the
graph so IJ such that both player I and
player J would
um would benefit from from adding that
so no pair jointly wants to add a link
Okay so
all right so we're thinking uh so for
now couldn't be stable it needs to be
robust to unilateral deletions of links
bilateral editions of links and and
unilateral changes to uh to the the
action profile and uh I'm you know
requiring strict linking incentives here
uh because
um in in differences going so so having
strict incentives is going to be
important for the for the
characterization if you have
indifference you can get a lot of uh
sort of different things happening
um
now one now one thing you might be sort
of thinking to yourself is you might say
well you know there might be some other
kinds of uh deviations that you want to
be robust to so for instance
um you know maybe a player could
simultaneously change your action and
you know delete several links or you
know do some other combination of things
um and you know you could you could very
much uh consider these things so I I
want you to understand this definition
of thinking about sort of a a minimal
set of deviations that we want the
stable outcome to be uh to be robust to
and you know if you if you want
robustness to additional deviations
you're only going to refine away outcome
so if I'm you know I'm going to give you
a theorem that says every stroke every
uh out uh graph in a strictly pair what
stable outcome has to have a particular
structure well if you refine away more
outcomes the result still holds
okay so I mean of course you might uh
you know if you want more robustness you
might have some issues with existence
I'm I'm not going to have a lot to say
about that in this talk
okay
um so as I said earlier I'm going to
spend most of my time uh focusing on a a
particular special class of network of
uh of these games that we call separable
games
um all that means is that the
um the payoff is going to take the
following the following form so so uh
player I is going to have some
idiosyncratic payoff that depends on the
profile of action so this is the I of s
and then there's going to be these
additively separable terms uh for each
for each link right so for every
neighbor J player I is going to earn
some uh some payoff G of sisj
okay
so again so this is um you know less
General than what our our results are
are ultimately going to cover but this
is going to be you know enough to
include all of the sort of toy
applications that we that we study in
the paper so I think there's maybe you
know two two substantive assumptions
that um I do want to point out about
this formulation so first is that
now the value of a link is um going to
depend on on the player's actions uh
right not their identities
okay so whether I want to form a link to
you or not doesn't depend on sort of any
particular like inherent attribute it's
depending on what action you're taking
um and the value and also the value of a
link is going to depend
um only on the actions of players
involved right so
um
you know if you have say a third friend
uh taking some other action that Friends
Action doesn't influence whether I want
to link to you or not at least not
directly
right so I I do want to point out that
there is going to be still
um indirect dependence
um on on others actions and links to the
extent that they affect your action
right so if you have a another friend
who you know is taking say a very high
action which induces you to take say
it's a game of strategic compliments
that induces you to take a higher action
the fact that you're taking a higher
action could you know change my linking
incentives
um but you know again the the the
influence of your sort of other friends
uh only matters because of its effect on
your action
okay
so just to you know help maybe fix ideas
with like a you know simple example uh
so here's you know uh one one game that
fits into this framework
uh so you can think of a players
exerting some uh some sort of effort so
say the action set is the positive reels
uh could be you know how hard you're
studying or how much effort you're
investing in committing crime something
like that and as a payoff uh would take
a sort of linear quadratic or really
just linear formulation so you're uh you
have some sort of private incentive for
effort these to buy uh
uh spillover term all right so that's
the the product of Your Action and your
and each neighbor's action
uh right and and scale through the
parameter Alpha and then there's sort of
two costs uh being written into here
right so thinking of the cost C1 is kind
of a direct cost of
um of effort uh five but then C2 well it
might depend on effort but really I you
might think of this as like a link
maintenance cost but but maybe the cost
of links could um increase an effort if
uh uh say actions and links are our
substitutes or maybe the cost of links
might might decrease in the first
okay so for instance in the in the
former case like if we're uh you know
thinking about this effort as like an
amount uh amount of effort studying well
maybe that makes it more difficult to
form friendships more difficult to
maintain relationships and so you might
expect
um C2 to be
um
uh increasing in in an effort then uh
versus you know maybe a fee the effort
is you know something sort of more
directly tied to like you know attending
and participating in social events well
maybe effort makes it more uh makes it
easier to form relationships and so in
that case uh maybe that that cost term
would be would be decreasing in the in
um an effort
okay
so I promised uh some some order
conditions right and uh and here they
are more formally
and so given a a separable network game
with network formation we're going to
say that actions and links are
complements
if you know basically whenever uh if I
wants to link to J given the actions sin
SJ well then if I raises her action to
SI Prime I still wants to link to J
okay and conversely actions and links
are substitutes if well whenever I wants
to form a link with J so this G term is
is non-negative it's beneficial to form
that link then if I raise this reaction
oh sorry if if I does not want to form a
link to J and I raise their actions to s
i Prime then I still does not want the
formula so that's that's the
substitute's case
and uh
likewise I'll say the game exhibits
positive spillovers right so if well if
I whenever I want to form a link with J
well if J raises her action to from SJ
to SJ Prime I still wants to form that
link
and we have negative spillovers if
whenever I does not want to form a link
with J I still doesn't want to form that
link When J raises her action
Okay so
again this is just exactly capturing the
idea that while Link Link action
complements substitutes captures the
idea of it taking a higher action myself
makes me more or less inclined to form a
link with others
for the compliments example you could
think of effort as partying for the
substitutes example you could think of
effort as studying
uh positive negative spillovers we're
you know thinking of this as uh you know
whether a higher action makes you a more
or less attractive neighbor so it was
one example so studying might make you a
more attractive uh neighbor because of
uh you know positive pure effects
um maybe maybe smoking has uh has
negative story which makes you a less
attractive neighbor
um now one word of caution I want to
uh say here is that you know you should
notice that these conditions say
absolutely nothing about
um whether the underlying game exhibits
strategic complements or substitutes now
holding the graph fixed right and
actually if we
get back to the the payoff function for
a little bit right if you realize that
in that sort of first term the vi of s
like any kind of strategic incentives
can be captured in that in that
idiosyncratic term so the game itself
could have strategic complements
strategic substitutes or neither
right so so this is really these two
types of order condition are really
about how
um how actions affect linking incentives
not how actions affect incentives for
other actions
okay
yeah now uh before restating the the
formal result I think it's you know
important to
um
just more precisely describe what these
classes of graphs look like
uh so so what if so I mentioned the
these two classes the nested split
graphs and the order overlapping plague
so what is a nested split graph
well a graph is a nested split graph
um if whenever uh vertex I has more
neighbors than vertex J
then every neighbor of J is a neighbor
of I so
um basically what this means is that
neighborhoods are are nested they're you
know ranked by set inclusion
um an equivalent way of uh defining a
nested split graph is to say that look
okay we can if we
partition the vertices based on their
degrees so let's have you know D Sub 0
is the set of uh nodes with with no
neighbors but then you know D1 is the
um set of nodes with the lowest degree
and you know DK is the set of nodes with
the highest degree
well then if you're in part if player I
is in Partition element DL
then I can tell you exactly who player
eyes neighbors are player eyes neighbors
have to be everybody in the L highest
partition elements
okay so in particular players with the
highest degree are ranked to everybody
that has any neighbors
the players in you know DK minus one are
linked to everybody except those in in
D1
right
etc etc
all right so then you know at the bottom
again so ignoring the people with no
friends in d0 the people in D1 are only
linked to those in DK the people when
the two are linked to those in DK and
then DK minus one
okay
uh the other class of graphs that are
going to be relevant to us are are what
we call order of lapping cliques and I
think probably the the easiest way to
describe these are to imagine
um you know that we can you know line
line the players up and uh put the
players on a line
uh in such a way that each player I
their their neighborhood is basically an
interval in that line and the endpoints
of that interval are sort of both
increasing in the izone position
okay
all right so so then with that it's uh
time to to revisit the main result
all right so if we're in the either of
the quadrants uh off the diagonal so we
have positive spillovers and Action Link
substitutes where we have negative
spillovers and Action Link complements
uh then we can say that look if you're
if you're a stable outcome the graph has
to consist of ordered overlapping clicks
and but in particular with the ACT
ordered based on based on players
actions
and so you know the players who are
going to be linked to one another the
neighbors of it's going to be taking you
know similar action levels those sort of
illustration over here on the right you
can kind of see that we have
sort of several uh dense little clusters
there's sort of two of them that sort of
intersect a little bit
um but again everybody's uh neighborhood
is
um sort of an interval of the action
space
if we're in the positive spillovers and
compliments case then we get this you
know the this hierarchical structure the
split graph and and the player is sort
of at the top of the hierarchy are going
to be the ones taking higher actions
like when the negative spill over the
substitute's case we get to flip that on
its head
okay
so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go through at least
a sketch of the proof of this but I'm
gonna do it by way of the more General
result
okay because what's what's really
important here
um
is is really just how
um
is really just have having this sort of
consistent ranking of who is a desirable
friend
so I'm going to introduce a couple sort
of more primitive conditions on on
references that are going to
um that are going to give us what we
need for the um for the the general
characterization and then I'll I'll show
why the um the result for separable
games is a special case
okay but now ultimately ultimately
what's going to matter is that you know
if um you know those who are more
desirable as neighbors uh also desire
more neighbors they're going to end up
with split rafts and if those who are
more desirable as neighbors desire fewer
neighbors we're going to end up with uh
with ordered clicks
okay so so building towards some more
General results let me introduce a
little bit of notation
all right so I'll say I'll write Delta i
j of uh UI this is sort of the the
marginal value of Link IJ to player I
um at uh at a particular outcome
okay
I'll write S Sub I plus of uh of a
particular outcome so this is the set of
uh individuals J who would be willing to
form a link with I
um given given this particular outcome
okay
all right I'm going to say that linking
incentives are consistent
right basically if you know while player
I and player J are are considering you
know whether they want to form a link
with two other players k and l
I'm going to say the linking incentives
are consistent if players inj always
agree on which of k l is more desirable
right so in particular all this all the
math says is that it can never be the
case that I wants to form a link with K
but not L and J wants to form a link
with L but not k
all right so we just want to rule out
that kind of preference reversal
the other the other condition
that we're going to need is what we call
alignment so we're going to say that
leaking incentives are aligned
um again sort of cutting through the
math basically if you know
uh no
J is uh sort of in between I and K in
terms of you know how desirable they are
as a neighbor then it must be the case
that Jay is desire for links is also
between that of I and K
okay so they get to say in a little bit
more precisely if the set of players
that uh once that want to link with Jay
is a superset of those who want to link
with I but a subset of those who want to
link with k then
well the set of players that Jay wants
to form a link to has to be similarly in
between
um the set of flares that I want to
wants to link with and the set of
players that K wants to link with
okay uh right so I'll probably I'll
probably skip a lot of approved sketch
that I'm happy to talk about that sort
of after uh after the talk but let me
just sort of I'll I'll State the Lemma
and try to try to get to the um the
application uh right so
okay so the the the the
the the Dilemma then is that so if
preferences are consistent and aligned
then any outcome we can basically find
uh orders and I'll say the the in order
think of that as the desirability order
and the out order as the sort of desire
for links order
um basically so that you know what this
in order means is that if K is ranked
higher than J in that order then K is a
more attractive neighbor to everybody
um and in the out order K is ranked
higher than J if K always wants more
links than J
um but not only that if preferences are
consistent in the line it's not just
that we can find these two orders
um if that the two orders have to be
either identical or reversed
yeah so we sort of have this this common
ranking of desirability and
um and desire for links so in the in the
interest of time I'll I'll skip the
um
the proof sketch but
um you know once we have this this this
basically ensures them uh you know one
of our two network architectures if
linking incentives are consistent and
aligned and uh DS is a strictly powered
stable outcome
um then well if the two orders are the
two orders that we get from the Lemma
are identical the graph has to be an S
to split graph and if the two orders are
opposed and the graph has to consist of
order vocal epic leaks
okay
yeah the the proof is actually really
really easy but I'll I'll I'll again
skip that to the interest of time
um but what I do want to spend a little
bit of time uh talking about is you know
let's let's go back to to think about
our separable Network games and how it
sort of fits into this um uh the these
uh more primitive conditions of uh
consistency and alignment
all right so
so let's recall you know what uh what
the payoffs look like in
um in the separable network games
all right so we had this you know
idiosyncratic uh leading term but the
the you know important terms for linking
incentives are this you know the the G
of sisj
so if you think about it so let's say
actions are ordered well you know if V
is increasing in its first arguments
um well then that's exactly saying that
I wants more links than J if and only if
um I is taking a higher action than J
right and if D is increasing in its
second argument that saying I has a more
attractive neighbor than J if normally
if I is taking a higher action than J
Okay so
so this is exactly so so if we're we
have linking incentives that take this
form and we have monotonicity and and uh
one of the two arguments then what then
we're sort of exactly getting
um uh the sort of the the relevant
orders
okay
um one other thing I should point out is
that you know we don't have to make the
linking incentives to pin directly on
actions okay so there's a very easy
generalization you could you know
compile some one-dimensional statistic
of a player's action and their sort of
idiosyncratic attributes say captured by
a type Theta right and as long as I can
sort of convert this into some
one-dimensional statistic and and make
the uh the linking incentives determined
by some G that's monotone in these two
arguments then exactly the same results
apply it's just that the um the relevant
ordering for the um uh for the results
is not going to be the order of the
actions it's going to be the order of
these um statistics
um and uh you know in fact like if you
if you want to make
um you know actions uh sort of trivial
let's you know make this a pure Network
formation game make it so that you know
players only have one available action
um
then this you know implicitly uh gives
you a result for uh for stable Network
structures when
um linking incentives are sort of
determined by one-dimensional types
um so it's a so very very simple result
but I think perhaps uh quite
surprisingly it seems that this is this
is new to literature
okay
let me give a quick recap so far so we
had our our sort of two
um primitive conditions that are uh
ensure that we have this you know Common
ranking and desirability and desire for
links
um so this uh if we if we have these two
orders and they agree we get nested
split graphs if they're opposed we get
ordered overlapping clicks
um just as you know one sort of large
class of games that always satisfies
these conditions where our um our our
separable games
okay so let's
let's go back to this
um
uh this purefx example and think a
little bit about how we might try to
capture the um
the sort of effects that were uh
observed in that in that Air Force study
okay so so as I said earlier you know I
I think it's it's it's reasonable to
view
um a sort of fear of X example is one
that has positive spillovers but link
action substitutes right so higher
actions studying harder is going to make
somebody a more attractive friend that
maybe make them less inclined to try to
try to form links yeah so here's a
a simple payoff function that's going to
have those properties
Okay so
there's we'll be making a an effort
Choice SI they have you know this um
private incentive bi for effort uh have
uh spillover terms that are scaled by by
Alpha and then there's this cost term
okay and what is this cost term well
it's uh proportional to the the you know
square of your your effort but it's also
increasing in the number of friends
foreign
okay so in particular uh you know if uh
if I increase my action it's going to
become more expensive to add more
friends if I have more friends it's
going to become more expensive to
increase my action
to increase my effort
so skipping some some algebra it's uh
you know fairly easy to show that well
okay in a pairwise stable outcome uh you
know players I and I and they are going
to want to are going to mutually want to
link with one another
um if and only if their their actions
are sort of separated by a
multiplicative Factor that's smaller
than two alpha
okay
again also skipping some algebra but
it's pretty easy to you know take a
first order condition and show that
um
you know the uh given the graph the
actions are going to be you know
effectively a weighted average of sort
of my own type and um and my neighbors
uh
my neighbor's actions
okay
all right so all right since we have
positive spillovers and Link action
substitutes we know that stable graphs
have to be ordered overlapping Peaks so
that's you know simplifies the analysis
of stable outcomes because you sort of
don't have as many as many possible
graphs to check
um so the the paper has you know a
number of sort of more more Dental
results but I think it's you know maybe
sort of more uh more helpful and uh in
the limited time of the talk to to just
look at a toy example okay
so so let's just suppose that our our
Squadron is going to have uh you know
five Cadets uh let's make this book over
term uh uh parameter one and we're gonna
think about there being three different
types of cadets right so uh sort of B
sub I the private incentive for effort
is going to capture sort of low medium
or or high ability or low medium or high
sort of preparation or test scores
coming in
so we can think about sort of three you
know different squadrons with different
compositions
all right so the first one having a bit
of two low types two mediums and a high
the second one we're going to replace
one medium with a high and then the
third one we're gonna have two lows and
and three highs
okay so we might think that you know the
first two would be you know kinds of
compositions likely to emerge when
you're doing random assignments uh
whereas the third one might be something
more like what you uh would have gotten
with the um the uh socially engineered
squadrons
okay so
turns out at least given these
parameters
um in the in the first two cases the
there's a unique pillow stable outcome
and it involves a complete graph right
so okay this is going to be just a
single uh a single Clique and since okay
the graph doesn't change when we you
know turn that middle type into a high
type uh everybody's still linked to each
other we're
um sort of getting the extra spillovers
for the low types uh the small change in
the composition is going to benefit
those uh those low type values
but
in the um in the last group all right uh
there is a pairwise stable outcome now
in which those sort of two um completely
separate cliques all right so the low
types are linked to one another take
each both of them take action for the
high types of link to one another both
take action nine so the the
multiplicative factor is greater than
two so there's not an incentive for
anybody to bridge the gap
um and so now we're not getting the uh
the beneficial spillovers for the for
the low types and they're actually doing
sort of significantly worse
all right so here's just a
illustration of the um the stable graphs
uh with um players uh labeled by their
uh types inside the circles and
equilibrium actions uh outside
okay I I guess my I understand that I'm
I'm basically out of time so maybe I
well this just
briefly mention uh some of the some of
the stuff on status games so
back to the last slide yeah
um so you're saying that the sort of
social welfare is harmed by allowing
people in the four four the third like
set of types to allow them to like sort
of organically decide linking decisions
is there a a group design where like
could you just partition this
differently like allow one of the fours
to only know about one of the nines and
the other four to only know like is
there a way to to still do group design
but have a higher Welfare by so
partitioning the world differently
um
so I think at least in this case because
just okay so this is you know definitely
sensitive to the way that we've written
down the payoffs but
um
you know for for this particular game
because the the separation between the
types is large enough if you have a
group that is only High types and only
low types uh you're there's going to be
a stable outcome where they're just
completely separated you're going to
sort of need there to be a type in the
middle that has incentives to form links
with them both that then might have a
chance of sort of bringing the their
actions close enough to each other so
that they'd be willing to form Lanes
right so in the in the first two cases
like having that middle type the type
six who
um you know is definitely going to want
to link to the type four is definitely
going to want to link to type nine uh
and it's also going to be you know
wanted as a neighbor for both that sort
of
it kind of acts as like a glue that
brings them together
there's still like a you know
big sort of larger design optimization
question oh absolutely
population agents and you can shuffle
them support them and sort them in the
closet yeah so I mean absolutely that's
just a a broader design question which I
you know that's some uh very much uh uh
part of my future agenda
um
okay not sure I have anything useful to
say about it just yet though
foreign
status Games application so
um
one one other uh application we think
about in the paper is uh so you know
imagine something like
um conspicuous consumption so
you know players could be you know
competing trying to you know show off to
each other but you know maybe there's
some you know the effort that you exert
sort of makes you a less attractive
friend so there's negative spillovers
um but you know if I'm spending a lot of
money trying to you know flaunt my
wealth I sort of you know might want
more connections because that's you know
how I how I create positive comparisons
for myself
um so so this would be an example with
negative spillovers and actually
compliments
okay so this is you know the the
opposite quadrant but so still
um in the uh
category that gives us uh ordered
cliques which you know broadly is is
sort of consistent with the kinds of
structures that have been observed in a
lot of uh sort of sociological studies
of this um kind of phenomenon and so in
in the paper we we do study again a toy
model
um based on uh uh the the model in one
of Nicole's papers so so that paper
taking you know the graph is exogenous
and looking at status competition in the
exogenous graph so we basically take
that model endogenize the network
formation uh together with the status
competition and uh have a couple of
those sort of high level results that we
can that we can say there is that you
know you find well first of all the
people in larger larger cliques or in
larger groups are going to be the ones
investing more effort
um but also that you know if you
increase players um status concerns make
them care more about these uh
comparisons than the um the social graph
is gonna fragment into smaller clicks
all right I think I'm out of time so
I'll be uh skipping right to the wrap up
um so now again I think you know it's
it's it's it's clearly important in a
lot of different settings to be able to
you know think about how connections
affect actions and vice versa so
um I think uh first and foremost the
point of this paper is trying to provide
a framework to you know formally study
these two things in tandem so we're
trying to you know unify a couple of
different literatures
um and at least with these results are
showing that at least you know in some
cases some very simple path properties
can give you quite
um I I should say very um uh
interpretable payoff properties can give
you quite sharp predictions
um that that do in fact capture uh
important features of real networks in
different contexts stuff so you know
there's a lot of I think uh you know
exciting directions for a few future
work we you know just sort of mentioned
um um group design I'm also you know
currently working on a on a follow-up
project trying to think a little bit
more about um uh sort of more uh more
General payoffs
um but
um I'll I'll leave it at that thank you
we have time for a few questions and and
then we can have a virtual hybrid coffee
break which I'll explain in a moment but
let's first uh think thank Evan with our
little clappy icons
uh we can take questions if you're in
the room you can ask questions on a mic
or actually I guess we discovered in the
last talk you should actually walk up to
the laptop maybe
um
but uh and in the virtual world you can
also walk up to a mic to ask questions
uh if you're interested I I can start it
off I was I'm really excited about the
sort of group design question and uh
something else that
I guess something in the back of my mind
after hearing a talk by Matt Jackson uh
based on his recent nature paper with
co-authors is like what's the optimal
size of a community so I organize a lot
of workshops and conferences on
interdisciplinary groups and I've always
felt like
I hate the aeas sorry guys I love like
little things like this
um because I feel like I actually get
more connections to more different types
and I know you don't have pipes in your
model but like you know it's still like
there could there could be types right
so I mentioned the sort of extension to
having these like as long as I can take
a type and an action and convert that to
a one-dimensional statistic everything
works out just fine so yeah uh yeah yeah
but so is there any sensitivity to the
number of agents in your model I guess
so in in this one not so much right and
so so so so so
um
at least with the the separable payout
function it's almost like we're assuming
there's a constant cost of of linking so
that you know if I right so if I uh want
to link with somebody you know who's
taking a particular action I'm going to
want to link to everybody who's taking
the higher action right and so you can
sort of see this also in like the split
graph prediction the people that sort of
the top of the hierarchy are going to
necessarily be forming large numbers of
links so so you know I think this the
model that I talked about today
um is really I think only going to be
you know you know appropriate if we're
thinking about sort of
um in network formation within a
relatively restricted reference group so
thinking about like something like a
classroom or like a workplace we're not
talking about Network formation within
like you know Academia a city or like an
entire university community not
something with like thousands of people
but like you know a community of like a
few hundred people who or if like an
administrative group of like a few
hundred people where you can sort of
realistically think about you know sort
of
um well you know Finding sort of all of
the individuals that you might be sort
of interested in in in connecting with
so the the
um the new project that I alluded to at
the at the very end so I'm actually I'm
I'm working now thinking about uh uh
a model in which the sort of uh convex
costs of of Link formation right so you
know you would think like well uh
we've got sort of a large number of
people to whom I could potentially form
form links with you might start to think
that I exhaust my resources for doing
that and there ought to be some sense in
which there's either diminishing returns
of links or increasing marginal costs of
links
um and that's definitely gonna that's
definitely gonna change the predictions
in a meaningful way
um
yeah give me a couple weeks to finish a
draft and uh I might be able to send you
a paper that's relevant
sick
um if there's other questions you can
navigate your avatar to a mic or type
them into the chats and uh
so I'm not sure if Rachel's trying to
ask a question but you can navigate your
your avatar to a mic if you would like
if to ask a question
um and I guess in lieu of that I just
wanted to make a few announcements first
of all uh thank you to the morning the
first two speakers I uh we can chat with
the speakers in the uh virtual coffee
room that we're currently in like this
the seminar the room that we're
currently in so Evan maybe you can
navigate to a table and and people can
go join that table to talk to someone at
a table you should actually like sit on
and put your avatar on one of the chairs
at that table
um
and uh
I guess it then we'll reconvene and
uh in 15 minutes to have the last Talk
of the virtual morning session and and
after that last Talk of the virtual
morning session I will tell people who
are physically in Berkeley uh how to
organize lunch groups so you don't have
to eat alone in your hotel rooms so
thank you and see you all in 15 minutes
no hello again you can stop the
recording here yeah great